LOUIS GRAY: Welcome to Google
Developers Weekly for
September 16, 2013.
I'm Louis Gray, and this is our
highlight reel of what's
happening in the world
of Google Developers
on the set and off.
While the weather here in sunny
Mountain View has been
pleasant, our GDL studios were
dominated by clouds last week.
Google's cloud platform team
delivered four separate videos
for you cumulus and stratus
aficionados.
Starting first with the core
benefits of the platform,
including rapid compute
scaling and
large scale data analytics.
The video series also includes
case studies from companies
like Rovio and Shutterfly,
letting us hear how they can
easily deploy what would
otherwise be a complex
infrastructure and reduced
latency while scaling to meet
spikes in user demand.
Google's mission is to make
the world's information
universally accessible
and useful.
That includes making content on
the web accessible to blind
in low vision users.
Internet pioneer Vint Cerf, TV
Raman and others from Google's
accessibility team, join us in
the GDL Studio to kick off the
web accessibility MOOC.
And as promised last week, the
Big Query duo of Felipe Hoffa
and Michael Manoochehri
introduced us to correlation.
Turning data and assumptions
into actionable information.
From Tel Aviv, Ido Green
delivered a two part series on
how to build a mobile
application using Google Docs
and Apps Script as
the back end.
And by the way, it's also
a very cool example a
bidirectional tech support
in an application.
Heading back to Cloudville
Jarek Wilkiewicz and Fred
Sauer showed us how to get
started with the YouTube API
using the cloud playground.
While from Buenos Aires,
[? Nick Bordalati ?]
discussed Cloud Endpoints.
From our Tokyo studio, Eiji
Kitamura continued his focus
on Web Audio, diving into the
midi API for more pure sound
in your browser.
Here back in Mountain View,
Google Analytics Jim
[? Contino ?]
and Andrew Wales went behind the
code to give us an inside
look at what's new in the
recently released Google
Analytics version
3 mobile SDK.
When it comes to
[? counting ?]
clicks on any device, real
time is the best time.
Wrapping our studio activity for
the week was Paul Saxman,
who introduced a brand new
show, "Maps The Mobile
Experience".
This week, Paul explored
techniques for building a
single handed smartphone
interface for browsing a
collection of photos on a map.
Oh yes, more cloud.
We're taking it on the road.
Registration is now open for
the Google Cloud Platform
developer tour.
Later this month and next,
we'll be visiting Tokyo,
London, Berlin, Paris, and Tel
Aviv for in depth talks on App
Engine, Compute Engine,
and platform services.
Come see us if you're going
to be in our neighborhood.
And you've probably heard of
Raspberry Pie, a small
inexpensive device that's
great for learning how
computing works.
We love Raspberry Pie.
And now we've build CODER, a
project the turns your pie
into a web server and
development environment.
Take a look at our project
page and get started with
CODER, and get all the kids
you know involved too.
To make sure you never miss a
thing from the world of Google
Developers, subscribe to Google
Developers on YouTube,
and check out the GDL schedule
at developers.google.com/live.
I'm Louis Gray, and I'll
see you in the studio.